the rel
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this first video i will be showing
you what i believe are some of the
greatest scenes from the very first
season of the show as you all know game
of thrones has given us a lot of amazing
moments over the years as a matter of
fact game of thrones delivered some of
the most unforgettable moments in
television history like ned stark's
execution the red wedding the battle of
the bastards and so much more now it's
no secret almost all of these amazing
scenes would happen at the end of the
season
the show became famous for having the
most shocking scenes in the 9th or 10th
episode what i want to do in these
videos is show you what i believe is the
best scene from each and every episode
of game of thrones i will start the
series off by showing you some of those
moments from season 1. hopefully you
will follow along with me on the journey
as we go through the whole show shall we
begin
season 1 episode 1 jaime lannister
throws brain stark out of the window i
would say this is without a doubt the
most shocking scene in the first episode
but i also think it's the best scene in
the episode for a number of different
the reasons i do for love
[Music]
this scene immediately showed us that
game of thrones would be unlike almost
every other show we've seen
not only did we see some of the main
characters engaging in an incestuous
relationship but we also saw one of them
throw a child out of a window knowing
full well it would most likely lead to
that child's death
now we all knew bran did survive the
fall but this was one hell of a way to
end the first episode of a new show by
the end of that first episode we knew
there would be a lot of focus on hal
stark not only were they given the first
introduction as a family but they were
also given an introduction before the
king himself
then at the end of this episode we see
that king's wife having an affair with
her very own brother a secret they would
have to keep safe otherwise robert
baratheon would have all of them
executed so when it was branstark that
discovered their secret we knew jaime
wasn't throwing any child out of the
window this was the son of ned stark the
warden of the north and the future hand
of the king he's not only one of the
most respected men in all of the seven
kingdoms but he also just happens to be
best friends with the king himself jaime
lannister throwing brain stark out of
the window was one of those moments that
indicated no one would be safe not even
in their very own home
season 1 episode 2 ned stark and jon
snow say goodbye now i will be honest
selecting only one scene from this
episode was much harder than i thought
it would be
there were some scenes that had a lot of
foreshadowing there were some other
scenes that were simply fun to watch
like when jon gave arya a needle or when
arya and nymeria beat up joffrey i mean
who doesn't like seeing joffrey get
humbled we all do but at the end of the
day there is no better scene in this
episode for me than when ned and john
say goodbye especially now that we know
they will never see each other again
is my mother alive
does she know about me where i am where
i'm going
does she care
the next time we see each other
we'll talk about your mother
hindsight makes this scene even better
because we now know exactly why ned was
safeguarding this secret about jon
snow's mother this is another reason why
this scene is so sad as you all know
this is when john begins asking ned
about his mother before he leaves jon
wonders if his mother has any love for
him at all unfortunately he doesn't know
that the reason why she hasn't been
around is because she's dead already you
can see this shatters ned's heart
because he almost starts crying before
the scene is over jon has no idea that
the last thing his mother ever did was
make sure that ned would keep him safe
not only did ned stark lie to his wife
about jon's mother but he also lied to
his best friend king robert who most
likely would have had jon killed if he
ever found out he was rhaegar's son
jon might not have felt it whenever lady
catelyn was around but there was a lot
of love for him at winterfell he just
didn't know it season 1 episode 3 jaime
lannister and ned stark reminisce this
is actually one of my favorite scenes
from all seasons
now we eventually see jaime and ned
fight with their swords later in this
season however i would argue this is a
much better scene because the way they
fight with their words here cut far
deeper than any sword
and laser
when i watched the mad king die
i remembered him laughing as your father
burned
it felt that justice
so will you tell yourself at night
you're a servant of justice
the amount of information we are given
in this scene alone is incredible not
only do we find out what happened many
years ago but we are also given even
more insight into who these characters
are as men
now we will also eventually see jaime
lannister go through a metamorphosis in
later seasons but in this moment ned
stark knows exactly what kind of man he
is jaime is known throughout the seven
kingdoms as one of the greatest
swordsmen who ever lived but in ned's
eyes that's really only because he
fights when fighting is safe this is
also when we find out exactly what
happened to ned's father and brother
jaime as well as 500 other men stood
there and watched as the mad king had
them burned alive ned must wonder why he
didn't kill the mad king then
why did him and his father wait until
the battle was basically won before they
joined robert's side it's the starks and
the lannister's bitter relationship with
one another that really drives this
first season and it was on full display
in this scene season 1 episode 4 lady
stark and the little lion if the starks
in the lannister's relationship wasn't
bad enough this really sent things over
the edge i can still remember the way i
felt when lady catelyn had lord tyrion
arrested during this scene
in the name of king robert and the good
lords you serve
i call upon you to seize him
and help me return him to winterfell
to await the king's justice
now this moment was great in itself but
it also led to some of this season's
other amazing moments like jaime
lannister fighting ned stark in the
streets of king's landing braun fighting
for tyrion during her first trial by
combat lord tywin lannister's amazing
introduction and much more none of those
scenes would have happened the way that
they did without this scene happening
first now we all know lady stark was
arresting the wrong man but i think this
made the season far more interesting
there were some other great scenes in
this episode but this one affected the
story immediately you could also say
this foreshadowed what was in store for
lord tyrion lannister because as we all
know he would get arrested again and
again
season 1 episode 5 the battle of varys
and littlefinger
now there were a lot of fun fight scenes
in this episode this is the episode
where we get our first glimpse of
cleganebowl when the hound and his
brother fought in front of a crowd of
spectators it's also the same episode
when jaime and ned fought after his wife
arrested his brother as great as those
moments are i think the mental sparring
varus and littlefinger do here is far
more interesting albeit maybe it's not
as exciting
but enough about me how have you been
since we last saw each other since you
last saw me or since i last saw you now
the last time i saw you you were talking
to the hand of the king saw me with your
own eyes eyes
watching these masterminds dance around
each other's threats is fascinating
because although they may rarely get
their hands dirty themselves we all know
how dangerous their information can be
with their little birds they are
essentially the eyes and ears of king's
landing if one of these men don't know
all of your secrets you can almost
guarantee the other one does it really
is a shame these characters only shared
a few scenes when they were still alive
near the end of the series i was really
hoping we would see them face off
against each other again they were among
some of the smartest characters in the
show it's unfortunate they were
sidelined the way that they were in the
later seasons watching this scene again
really made me miss the varys and
littlefinger of old season 1 episode 6
danny watches her brother burn i mean
who doesn't love this scene watching
viserys die gave me more satisfaction
than a thousand lying [ __ ] it's among
some of the most satisfying death scenes
on the show only behind joffrey's ramses
and walter freys
[Music]
[Applause]
the other reason why this scene is so
great is because it also shows us
danny's dark side
this was a great example of what could
or would happen if daenerys ever reached
a breaking point season 1 episode 7 the
arrest of ned stark now this was not
easy there are so many other great
scenes in this episode i would argue
it's one of the best episodes in the
whole show the very first scene is the
introduction of tywin lannister arguably
the greatest introduction of any
character this scene right after that is
when cersei tells ned when you play the
game of thrones you win or you die there
is no middle ground that's arguably one
of the best lines in the show this is
the same episode when jon snow says his
night's watch vows and it's also the
same episode where robert baratheon dies
if we would have actually seen robert
baratheon die in a scene i might have
selected that one because of how much it
affected but since we don't see that
happen i have to go with the next best
thing when ned stark is arrested i don't
know about all of you but i was shocked
the first time i saw ned stark get
arrested especially by that snake
littlefinger of all characters
i did warn you not to trust me
now as angry as i was i cannot deny that
it's one of the greatest moments in
television history i was expecting ned
to essentially seize the iron throne in
that moment it looked as if everything
was set up for him to do just that i
remember thinking finally the lannisters
are about to be thrown out of king's
landing but then to go from that high to
seeing ned stark one of the most beloved
characters get arrested is one hell of
an emotional roller coaster that single
action by cersei and littlefinger
effectively rearranged everything arya
would run rob would fight and
unfortunately ned would die in one way
or another the lannisters would remain
on the iron throne from this day until
the very last day of game of thrones
season 1 episode 8 down goes danny and
drogo when carl drogo rips out that
man's throat that is actually one of the
very few moments george rr martin said
he wished he had written for himself
he'd love that dan and dave added that
into the scene now as fun as that is
that's not the only reason why i think
this is one of the best scenes from this
season who would have thought that such
a little scratch would have had the
impact that it did and only the very
last episode drogo announced that he
would go to westeros and wreak havoc on
the seven kingdoms i don't know about
all of you but i was really looking
forward to seeing what would happen when
drogo and his men faced off against the
knights of westeros
what made this thought even more
exciting was the fact that robert
baratheon was so afraid of this
happening he knew what the dothraki
would do if they ever made it on the
shores of westeros but then this little
scratch stopped everything
this scene would result in not only the
death of carl drogo but his and danny's
unborn child as well
this even affected any future children
dany would have because as we all know
she would never have another child of
her own again it really is amazing how
these small moments are like butterfly
effects that alter the direction of the
show throughout the remaining seasons
right when we thought danny and drogo
were about to storm westeros she would
not land on its soil until many many
seasons later season 1 episode 9 the
death of ned stark i didn't even have to
think about this one ned stark's death
is one of the biggest moments in all
eight seasons
in fact it's one of the most shocking
moments in television history this was
without a doubt the moment every single
fan knew no one was safe ned stark was a
main character who looked like he would
one day take over the iron throne he
shouldn't die in the first season things
like this don't happen very often in
television or film
from this day moving forward game of
thrones was known as the show that would
kill off any character no matter how
much they were loved as a matter of fact
the more a character was loved the more
likely it seemed that they were gonna
die even still to this day it's hard for
me to watch that scene
the effect this had on game of thrones
was immeasurable and his death would be
felt all the way up until the very end
season 1 episode 10 the dragons are born
this is without a doubt one of the most
significant moments in all of game of
thrones once again everything was about
to change after the introduction of
danish dragons
drogo will have no use for dragon eggs
in the nightlands sell them you can
return to the free cities and live as a
wealthy woman for all your days they
were not given to me to sell
it was now only a matter of time before
they made their mark on the realm the
dragons would wipe out cities burn the
dead and even knock down the wall that
stood for over 8 000 years dany most
likely would have never survived as long
as she did without her dragons but in
the end they would be her downfall as
well dany hatching her dragon eggs was
one of the most magical moments in game
of thrones but i wonder if she would
still think it was worth it after
knowing where they would ultimately lead
her leave me some of your thoughts down
below let me know why you agree or
disagree with some of the scenes on the
list i will do the scenes for the second
episode and my very next video hopefully
you will join me on this journey as i go
through each and every episode from game
of thrones if not i want to thank all of
you anyway for watching my video
have a great day everyone bye
[Music]
so
you